[Music]
i found the love of my life in germany
this past march she went to the hospital
she never made it out of the hospital i
ended up having to take her off the
ventilator on april 7th she was only 32
years old it's literally the only thing
i've ever asked god not to do to me
and and it's happened
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney show
talking about mental health
relationships whatever's going on in
your life most everything going on in
your life not everything but most of it
we're here to walk alongside you if you
want to be on this show give me a buzz
at 1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
ask so glad that you're listening to the
show and sharing it with your friends
and family the calls and and
the notes and cards and letters are i'm
just so grateful so thank you so so much
all right let's go uh directly to the
phones let's go to elijah in austin hey
what's up elijah how are we doing
i i don't even know how to really phrase
this question i guess i'll
i'll lead with the most shocking
part of it i feel
um portrayed
betrayed by god
and i'm very angry at him right now and
i need to figure out
how to get past this
man number one just i don't even i don't
even know where we're headed here but um
thank you for being brave out of the
gate man
um
what are you betrayed and angry about my
man
okay um retired army
um i've been to iraq afghanistan kosovo
germany
tons of places
um
so i've been the hill
and i've accepted it
and in my prayers
the only thing i ever asked god for
was to uh not put my
put me in my marriage
what my mom went through which um my dad
died of
colon cancer when i was nine
and i watched it breaker
and um
i found the love of my life in germany
we got married in in 2013.
um a week after we got married we found
out she was pregnant
um two weeks after we got married we
found out that she had stage three
inflammatory breast cancer
so
so we went through the whole pregnancy
with cancer
we got through it
um
she never expected to live very long
um
her
her
mission in life was to give birth to our
youngest son and she told me um
you know when i pass away it's it's your
job to take care of them i'm just going
to get them here
so that was kind of the plan and then
um
we were blessed and
and um
things continued on for eight years with
her being you know
little flashes of cancer but mostly in
remission
and um this past march she went to the
hospital
she had a small tumor she was supposed
to get some routine surgeries and they
were going to you know they had a whole
treatment plan and everything
and
she never made it out of the hospital i
ended up having to take her off the
ventilator on april 7th
four days after my birthday
um she was only 32 years old
and it's literally the only thing i've
ever asked god not to do to me and and
it's happened and now i'm here
you know almost three months later
with four kids in the house
um
we started building our dream house um
back in november i closed on that on
thursdays with two days
and it all feels wrong because yeah this
whole dream was was for her and she's
not here to enjoy it
yeah and
and i'm just trying to figure out how to
navigate through that
if you were sitting with me right now
um
i'd give you a hug
and i would hold the hug past the time
when it was
awkward
to when you could feel
my body telling your body that i love
you and i'm sorry
what's happened to you should happen to
nobody
i'm sorry man
thank you
how old are your little ones
17
14
13 next week and eight
so first three are from a previous
relationship but um she was definitely
the mom of all these kids sure oh
well that means three of them have
experienced loss twice now huh
yes okay
so
man i'll give you all time you need what
where do you want to start when you
start with
[Music]
nuts and bolts what comes next we can
start with god we can start with
you
we can start with parenting where do you
want to start man you tell me
wherever you want to take me um i'm
willing to go
well you totally lost yeah you too
um let's start with god
um
so
the best i can
in my study for those listening i'm a
person of faith okay
um
probably not a traditional person of
faith um i tend to make everybody
uncomfortable wherever i go
um but the best i can dig into it is you
got about four options okay elijah
that god's not real
none of this is real
that god's absent he's a clock maker he
spun the thing up and then walked away
from it just it's going to be what it's
going to be
the third option is god caused this for
some grand reason
and he could only do his grand reason
with a trail of devastation and
heartbreak and loss
or the fourth
is that god can't or god
doesn't cause this type of god doesn't
cause cancer he doesn't let cancer
happen
and then in fact when cancer happens and
cancer takes everything that god's with
you in the smoke and the ash
and unfortunately
there's
church systems
built around all these different
pictures
fortunately you get to pick
and what i would tell you as someone
who's seen it all
you've been all over the world as you
said you've been to hell
um i had a very clear understanding
because i read a lot
and then i started sitting with people
who had died
i started cleaning brains off of walls i
started helping move bodies
and then my picture shifted dramatically
okay
and so
at this point in my life and again feel
free to leave mean comments internet
people
i don't believe in the phrase things
just happen for a reason i do believe
that reasons and meaning can be made
from pain
i do believe that
so all that to tell you is
if you believe in god
he can handle your anger he can handle
your rage
feel free to feel betrayed feel free to
be heartbroken
all of those feelings are right and good
and i would even say they're holy
okay
not for a second
remember if you're a christian that
jesus got down on his face in the garden
the night before and said can we do this
another way
right
yeah
so feel free to be upset and heartbroken
and mad
the next step is
people around you are going to say the
dumbest stupidest things
because we have no capacity for being
uncomfortable
and so when somebody else gets cancer
when somebody else gets sick when
somebody else loses a loved one we get
uncomfortable we don't know what to do
with that
and so
um
we wrap those things up in stupid little
sayings that we knit on pillows or put
in greeting cards
like god needed another angel or
it was just her time or
you'll find love against people say
stupid things like that that are painful
and hurtful and what i would tell you is
um
let that go like a vapor okay okay don't
hang on to that that's people trying to
love you and love themselves in the only
uneducated unskilled way that they know
how and it's exhausting and frustrating
just let that
go like like cotton candy okay
um
however you reconcile god's
participation in this is
i mean you can find scripture to back up
whatever you want to think about it
quite honestly
and so it really comes down to
what helps you get to the next day into
the next day into the next day and where
do you find peace
and i'll tell you peace is gonna be a
long time coming for you
okay
do you remember back in basic
way back then do you remember basic
training
yes how long was yours six weeks
um nine weeks plus another six weeks and
and i was lucky enough to join like two
months before 9 11. so it was it was bad
okay
so you remember on week one of that six
weeks
you knew there was an end date to this
thing
yes and when we have an end date we can
do anything
but you also remember when the drill
instructor would say you're gonna run
till i get tired watching you
yeah it was hell right because you
didn't know how long we were running
what you need to understand is you've
entered a space
that there's not a termination there's
not an end date on when the hurt stops
and so as a person who seeks control in
situations which is what you're going to
want to do
i'm going to tell you to start opening
your hands up
and probably i'm just guessing that
because you're a military guy i may
correct me if i'm wrong your tendency is
to walk into a situation especially one
of chaos and find control asap
yeah
and that's the opposite thing that you
need to do here you need to fight that
impulse with everything you got
you're going to have to you're going to
feel underwater you're going to feel
like you're going through the motions
you're not going to be able to breathe
something you're not going to be able to
taste and then occasionally you're going
to smile and you're going to laugh
or you're going to see a really
beautiful woman at work and then you're
going to be overcome with shame and
guilt and frustration and anger and
that's just gonna start to loop am i on
to something
yes okay
myself you're allowed to laugh
and you're allowed to wake up for that
one moment when you forget that she's
gone and think that was a hell of a
night of sleep
and you're allowed to see somebody who's
beautiful and think man she's beautiful
that's not a betrayal of your wife okay
this is your body learning how to do
basic things again and it's gonna have
to relearn
all right so i just i threw a lot at you
there i'm gonna stop tell me what you're
thinking what you're feeling
um well i'm writing everything down
because because you're because you're a
military guy
yeah
yeah and um yeah this is stuff i want to
look at and study and
everything is just true everything i
mean it's been almost three months
so i've gone through all of this and
i've kind of
just
taken it day by day and um
i'm looking at the new house as an
opportunity to get away from all other
people saying stupid things
where no one really knows me so um
yeah this is this is all here's here's a
frustrating thing about other people
kind of like if you were dropped if you
got dropped in the
ocean and you were there for
six days
and you were rescued
what's the first thing you would need
is
water
the thing that almost killed you
is the first thing you need
it's a different kind of water in fresh
water but you need water
and so isolating yourself from people
is going to be helpful
sort of but the only way through grief
like this of this magnitude
because this is shape shifter right the
only way through grief of this magnitude
is with other people
and so i get the impulse to hide i've
got some i've never experienced grief
like you're going through i cannot put
my head in your seat right now looking
at my two little kids and the thought of
my wife not being here i can get choked
up real fast thinking about it
because i don't i have gone all in to
the point that i don't
understand how i would take a next step
what i know is you just do
and when i can't take another step
that's when my friends and community are
there
okay
so i'm gonna rattle some things off for
you right now
um and you don't have to write these
down um in fact i will uh i'll type
these up and i'll send them to you how
about that i'll email it to you and um
that way you can just listen
if you don't already you've got to get
some men in your life asap okay
okay right away
the second part of that immediately is
you've got to get very clear and brave
about speaking your needs out loud
i need someone to help do my yard
because i can't get out of bed today i
need someone to help with my wife's
closet
because every time i go in there and see
her clothes i can't breathe
okay okay
that's probably not your style it's
probably not your jams to tell people
you need help with stuff you're the guy
that people call when they need help
yes
it's time for you to
uh do the brave hard thing and that's
ask for help i need a group of people to
commit to making me food for the next 30
days because i can't when i get home
from whatever i'm doing during the day
and i see my eight-year-old i can't move
because my eight-year-old looks just
like my wife
okay
and you should be very specific about
those the third thing is and i'm just
throwing this out there okay people are
gonna be mean to be on the internets i
don't care
um as hard as it i don't go run out and
get remarried okay
no that's definitely not the plan okay a
lot of
the data on people who run out and
within 90 to 120 days are remarried is
astounding
and i get it there's this idea that i'm
just gonna fix this pain right now i
hurt so bad
um i'm so lonely i'm so i feel like my
part of my lungs are gone because they
are right
you're gonna have to do things on your
own
that means you're gonna have to get a
group of guys that you go fishing with
once a week that you get together and do
chips and queso with that you go grab a
drink with that you go hang out with
the tendency is to lock down and make
your life about those four kids
and that any minute you're not with them
is somehow abandoning them too on top of
your wife's passing and that's not
accurate
you've got to stay whole and well
they can't feel like they it's their
responsibility to make sure dad's okay
it's not their job okay
and kids are super perceptive and
they're super loving and they will take
that role on and it's really tempting to
drop our shoulders and let them run the
house that's too much weight for a 17 or
a 15 year old or a 14 year old or an
eight-year-old to carry
they need their daddy
which means dad needs to go exercise
daddy's to eat right dad needs to have
guys he goes and does stuff with whether
that's going to the gym shooting hoops
whether that's getting together once a
week and grandma comes over whatever
that looks like okay
okay um how are you financially you said
you're buying a house this sounds like a
big old mess
um i'm great financially i'm retired um
my income is over
six figures being retired so i'm good
excellent okay was there a life
insurance policy on your wife
yeah for um
six figures as well so obviously just
kind of in a money market
okay
um do you feel comfortable moving into
this new house
yes okay
um
the rule of thumb that my the guy who
trained me was actually a counselor and
he's then he became my supervisor um
the guy who trained me
said no major decisions for six months
to a year
so if you can breathe inside that home
that was quote unquote y'all's home
move in and just sit for a bit
okay
let the smoke clear and let the ash
clear of the explosion that just
happened and then you can assess the
situation it's taking a step back right
that's it's bacterial military training
yeah we're gonna we're gonna step back
and re-um
like take it take a new inventory of the
landscape there that one's hard
um and then over that course of six
months to a year man that's when you
start to reimagine your life i had this
plan and now i got a new one am i going
to live here am i going to move am i
going to get a new job am i going to go
to med school like what am i going to do
and culminating in that end of that is
that one scary terrifying question which
is
what are we going to do now
right
this is not the time for
bravery i can do it all myself
this is time for sitting down and
dropping your rucksack on the ground and
weeping
and saying why me
okay okay
this is saying those magic words to your
kids i don't know
okay
okay
where are we at now
um
there's a little bit of
clarification
um
what should i look out for
um
with the kids with
their mom their mother figure being gone
is there something
um specifically that i should do
um i mean i've gotten us into church
since since she passed um and i got her
buried two miles from the new house
which is why i'm going there so we can
grieve that did they go to the did y'all
have a funeral
yeah the kids go
yes okay
um
an important thing is to say your name
an important thing is to
acknowledge her
an important thing is when those kids
come in and one of them just randomly
starts crying and can't they're just
they'll be cutting a sandwich in the
kitchen
and we'll drop the knife and you'll
think they chop their finger off and
they fall to the floor weeping
that you don't go say get up quit
whining that you go sit on the floor
with them and hold them
okay okay
um
think of this as a raging river
that just broke the dam
trying to rebuild the dam while that
thing is running is of no use the best
thing to do is to let that water run
right
okay that system's got to equalize
itself
and for your eight-year-old it may for
all the kids it's gonna take it may
equalize over a lifetime
okay
um i'm gonna save the watch out for this
is in this let's get six months down the
road and i want to talk with you i want
you to you and i to to catch back up
okay
um
instead of looking for what's wrong i
want you to double down on connection
even if you said something like i want a
daily hug with all of you 20 seconds a
day 30 seconds a day
and if you're not a hugger it's time to
get weird man
okay
okay and say i want morning hugs and
nighttime hugs and if your older ones
are like dad am i hugging you your kids
like i don't hug you they don't have to
don't force them but
say um
i need hugs i want hugs
i want to give hugs
and like i said there's that moment when
you hug somebody and then they hug you
back and then they relax and then they
get tense again and if you can hold a
hug through that
then their whole body goes limp
and that's what we're looking for
true connection
okay
so um i threw a ton at you
i'll uh
we'll type up some notes and send them
to you and then we'll clip this call and
get it sent to you right away okay
okay it'll be rough and uncut but we'll
get it to you right away
um i'm also gonna send you a copy of my
new book
in no way shape form or fashion is it
gonna solve your i mean you're just in
the throes of deep deep grief and you
need to be there for a while okay
okay um
but it will give you some tools on how
to navigate it's basically like a raft
um and some and some
some rowing instructions for when you're
in that river it can't get you out of
the river but it can tell you how to
navigate a little bit okay
great thank you all appreciate it um and
know that i'll walk alongside you every
step of the way okay call me anytime
email me anytime reach out on instagram
anytime and i will um i'll make myself
available as i can to you man
um
[Music]
thank you for giving everything you gave
everything
and your wife sounds like she was a
powerful strong extraordinary woman and
i'm sorry this happened
[Music]
and um
for people who are listening if you
disagree with my theology that's fine
you can come meet at my house you're
still welcome over
and
elijah if you end up being you know i
disagree with you great man
i'm interested in you finding peace
it's been my experience that god shows
up in the ashes
[Music]
so i feel a little bit less alone or a
lot less alone
and often when the smoke clears
i've stopped asking the question where's
god and i start asking the question
where's god's people
and so i hope you your church will rally
around you too
i love you man and thank you for being
brave and thanks for calling
we'll be right back
hey what's up daloni here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back man this has been
a
heavy one let's go out to leslie in
arlington what's up leslie
hey dr john how are you
good it's been a heck of a show so far
how are you i'm i'm i'm good i think i i
took that deep breath just as you did
wow yeah
man so how can i help what's up
well um i am calling to get a little bit
of advice from you on navigating the
crazy world of youth sports um recently
i had my first experience exactly yeah
yeah i basically had my eye was blown
off my face whenever i had this
experience and then started talking to
all the different parents that are
navigating this journey as i am
um recently i had my eight-year-old try
out for a baseball team nothing crazy
you know um
and he did well he he does well with
sports you know we have him in all kinds
of sports nothing you know nothing crazy
just recognizing stuff
he's eight he's a little eight-year-old
boy and um so we ended up trying out for
this team and i ended up getting
this long email back from the coach um
and he was telling me how talented my
son was and how you know he did really
really well and then it started taking a
different kind of turn and as i'm
reading through it i'm like wait a
second the coach is talking about um
how there's this challenge with uniforms
and
there's this travel team that he's part
of and that they have decided at the end
that because they wouldn't be able to
get the uniforms back in time
um for the tournament that he had you
know had tried out for to get this team
to play in
um
the coach said we'll have to go with all
of the travel team players that already
have the uniforms and i'm like what
what what is this um i read a couple
times i'm like wow so you know we really
are selecting
you know
you know these young kids based off of
uniforms you know versus talent and it
really it just took me a few steps back
like wow wow wow wow these are
eight-year-olds um
and i really kind of i talked to a bunch
of parents and i'm like is this is this
normal is this like a one-off thing you
know did i just have a really bad
experience
and
i was blown away by the feedback because
it seems like everybody that has
children that are interested in sports
are kind of navigating the same path
where you either you know play in one
type of rec league or you invest
thousands of dollars into travel
whatever travel team you want to put
that kid in and it kind of locks them in
for only playing that sport because the
requirements are so intense and
i'm in the medical field so i have a bit
of a background on like you know
development and everything like that and
i'm like what are we doing to our kids
like
why are we all standing by and and not
like waving our hands and saying enough
is enough this is insane yes if i made a
decision you know cause i'm like okay i
feel crappy either way whether i respond
back to this coach or not so i decided
you know what i just i feel like i need
to say something so i wrote back and
just said you know
i'm really challenged with understanding
the philosophy behind your decision
making because
they're eight-year-old kids you know
whoever's the best tell me my kid isn't
good enough that's fine
that's a great lesson to teach him you
know you got to work hard for the things
you want
you know and
what ended up happening i brought it
senate i got an even longer email back
really you know him discussing with me
in depth how challenging this decision
is about uniforms i mean it went on and
on and on
and he was upset that i would question
his
ethics with coaching leslie
leslie
yeah do you want this man having
influence over your child
oh absolutely not no and that's the
thing it's like walk away yeah i mean
absolutely walk away totally well but it
kind of brought me up to the point of
you know i'm one of many people that are
out there that are in a situation where
our kids you know they're eight we're
going to be walking this path for quite
some time and i knew we you know
everybody's going to at some point of
course but it ate it really took me back
like these are just little guys and
really looking at your advice on how to
really more so communicate this to your
kids you know you want to be truthful
but you don't want to give them too much
information you know whatever is
appropriate
you know and you know life's not fair
and that's a lesson to teach them for
sure
but um what are your thoughts on how
we get through this um
you know yeah so i got i got a lot of
thoughts on this um my thoughts were
originally informed by you know you know
i worked at colleges forever and i would
always
i was a i was an athlete and so i would
always end up hanging out with the
athletes hanging out with um not so much
athletes as much as coaches were my
friends and the trainers from my friends
and it started about a decade ago when
my training friends
friends who were trainers at college
athletic trainers
were telling me that they were starting
to see young people come through
with joint use injuries seen in the
elderly
from over-specialization
and year-round sporting practices
and a lack of unstructured play in
multiple sports
and then that just so that was just a
thing in my head like
what what do you mean it's like oh the
kids don't play
baseball and then they all play soccer
then they all play basketball and then
they get to middle school and they play
football too and then they run track
no at age six they play baseball and
then they get a hitting coach and a
pitching coach and they make the select
team and it plays in fall and then in
spring and there's a summer league
and you're already specializing as a
shortstop at age seven right
yeah and so
that was number one that was the madness
call number one what are we doing why
and then
um number two was the
insane rise in childhood anxiety and
depression
and then
i started seeing the rise in adult
anxiety and depression
and then as i dug into the literature on
the kids i realized the kids are simply
responding to their environments and the
environments are created by the adults
and then i had my own son
and
he's a great athlete he's a phenomenal
athlete and to him he's just kind of a
go with the flow guy and he's really
good
and it i remember my first um game that
i went to the coach we had the first
coach was phenomenal magnificent human
being
but i remember the first game and i
remember thinking i have to decide now
if i'm going to get in a fist fight or
not because i'm not going to let that
dad talk to those kids that way on the
as a dad on the team
and i knew if i go say something to that
hothead i'm going to end up in a
physical altercation and i was having to
make that decision and it was a field of
six-year-olds or five-year-olds or
whatever it was
and
so
you said it best
it's the parents fault full stop that
we've allowed this to get this way
it's abusive and i use that word
intentionally and i had somebody email
me and say i overuse that word i don't
we're torturing our children
by forcing them to live vicariously
through our
either achieved or failed athletic
adventures and somehow parents have
come to put our self-esteem
like there's some sort of checklist that
if our kids makes good grades and
they're good at sports that that's
somehow a performance car scorecard for
us as parents right
and so we've created this world
and so i go loop back to to answer your
question i loop back to how do you tell
your kids
you could i don't think it's
developmentally appropriate you could
tell your kid
well you just found out
you may not get the job not because you
weren't the most talented but because
somebody knew somebody that's just the
way that works or because they had a
nicer suit on in the interview
um that is the how the world works by
the way and that could very much happen
i don't know that an eight-year-old is
gonna get anything other than bitter and
anxious about that so i don't know that
i would tell them that
what i would say is this i have preached
to my kids since they were little i've
got one job on the planet
and i can say it right now to both of
them what's my one job and my kit my son
rolls his eyes and he's like to keep me
safe and my daughter won't even say it
anymore she just looks at the ground
because she's like she's just annoyed by
it
and that phrase my job is to keep you
safe
includes intellectually psychologically
spiritually and physically
and so when my kids say hey why won't
you give us a smartphone
we're nine and everyone else in the
classroom has a smartphone at nine
i'll say what's my one job
to keep you safe
and when i tell my son hey we're not
playing in this league which i've done
we're not i'm not going to do this
league
not because i don't want to drive you
around not because i can't afford it
it's but it's because i don't want you
thinking
that the end result here is in any way
uh shaping you in a positive direction
because it's not
i do think playing sports is really
important and one of the rules is when
our kids have to do a thing they have to
play something
whether it's jiu jitsu whether it's
soccer whether it's it's wreck baseball
whether my son's in the cro he's a track
and cross-country guru uh he's really
good at that so you got to do something
you got to do something physical and you
got to do something as part of a team
that's that's important i think the
evidence would bear that out
um i am intentionally opting out of any
sort of pre-professional training
until my kid is a junior senior in high
school then we will start having hard
conversations about what's next until
then it is play first and when they ask
why can't it be on this and why can't i
do that my job is to keep you safe and i
don't want you around the mess the toxic
nonsensical idiotic parents
i'm not going to use that language by
the way that was between me and you that
was between me
no no check check check you you nailed
it but but i think i think telling my
eight-year-old you didn't make the team
they had a bunch of different criteria
that wasn't just about who's the better
baseball player well what do you mean
they had all kinds of things about
uniforms and other things
and i'm opting for you to not play in
that league
we're going to go play baseball here
or this summer we're taking the summer
off
yeah
and that's ultimately you know sorry for
the long rambling you know you you're
absolutely right it is it's like yeah
we're not going to do that we're going
to a different one because that i would
you know you're not going to be
influencing my child the most precious
gift
um but it you're absolutely right it's
absolutely bananas to see how
even for me like how these kids identity
is being tied to their performance
whether it's but they're getting that
from us
yeah absolutely yeah and i don't want my
kid you know what you don't want my
eight-year-old to do have fun yeah i
want him to learn hey if if you strike
out it costs your team i think that's a
good lesson i don't have any problem
with that i think it's great
i want him to know hey if you stay up
till 2 a.m at a sleepover party and have
nothing but donuts and m ms and you
strike out four times the next day i
want i wanted to begin to to connect
right your behavior yesterday impacted
your whole team today that's a good
lesson
yeah but i want him to have fun
yeah i want my kid to play he's got the
rest of his life to have the world tell
him that he sucks at everything that
he's not good enough
it reminds me of this
um and i may have mentioned this on the
show they're back in the early ufc days
in the in the um the valley tudo days
way back in the day my favorite fighters
in the world came out of a gym out of
brazil it was vandaly silva and shogun
hua and all these guys they were
incredible but here's how they trained
they just got in fist fights every day
and they knocked each other unconscious
that was how they trained
and now you fast forward 30 years later
and they did that because if you can get
through our practices like a fight with
another
professional will be nothing it will be
nothing
right until they started showing up
several years later with
um
brain injuries and repeated knee and
elbow and hand injuries
and hip injuries and what they've now
realized is they they save heavy hard
sparring
for rare times and everybody's padded up
to the max
because we're only going to go full tilt
when we're getting paid for it in a ring
and so i tell you to say i hear the
argument my kid needs to toughen up and
he needs to learn the world will be glad
to beat your kid up
you doing that when he's 8 9 10 11 14 is
nonsense
let your kid run around in the street
with a stick and a ball and some mud let
your kid go to the pool let your kid and
save the gas money by the way gas is
expensive right now
i would love dude i would love to see
just a parent's rise up across the
country it would take one facebook post
all travel sports are canceled this
summer we're not doing it we're not
going to pay 900 to prop up um a bunch
of adult egos we're not
and i by the way i've got no
trouble with with uh travel ball a
little league world series is great i
think that stuff's good and when the
coaches are great the coaches are
phenomenal
and we've had some remarkable coaches
remarkable dick coach david amazing guy
goes charlie coach those guys are so
great and we've got some other ones that
just can't get it can't parents and
whatever man
all let's say
let your kids play
keep them safe psychologically
emotionally spiritually physically best
you can you gotta let them hurt you you
gotta let them fall down that's not me
i don't mean i don't mean bubble wrap
them
and don't let them have any scars that's
not that's not right
[Music]
they gotta take their lumps
but they can't prop up our fragile adult
egos
leslie your kid's lucky to have
get him out of that nonsense and let him
go play he's only eight
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
suite 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
all right let's hey let's take one more
let's just make this a five hour show
let's take one more and go to james in
uh bend oregon it sounds like a yoga
pose gone wrong what's up dude
hey how you doing we're rocking and
rolling man how are you
pretty good i am wondering um what i can
do to help my fiance
dream about the future more and
talk with me kind of about what her
dreams are
tell me more
so
um you know we've been obviously dating
for quite a few years and we're going to
be getting married in about a year
and so you know i like to talk with her
about kind of what our future plans are
and
i'm the kind of guy who i've known what
i've wanted to do since i was a little
kid and you know i'm in that kind of
career path now and
she doesn't really know
what she wants to do and so she's having
a real hard time
kind of figuring out what that is and
when i try to talk with her about it she
says it kind of makes her anxious and
she doesn't want to talk about it
and
i'm kind of just wanting to know what i
can do to to help her because i don't
really
get anxious like that about stuff so i
don't really understand
why it's hard for her
so
the short of it is you can't
you
she's got to choose to do that
um so
the only conversation i can have here is
with you and so i want to shift the
focus from her to you is that cool
yeah
so my first question to you would be
have you created a
safe relational context for her to dream
about something
so i'm imagining and i'm just gonna
start throwing stuff up against the wall
and you tell me if it sticks okay
okay you've known what you've wanted
since you were little
and maybe you started dating her and you
were very clear about your destination
and your dreams and where y'all you
wanted to go
and then she fell in love with you and
she liked your drive and she liked where
you wanted to go
and you've known where you want to go
and so you went to college to go where
you want to go like you see what i'm
saying and now when you look at her and
say well what do you want
however long you all have dated it's
been very clear that what we are going
to do is what he wants to do
okay
so my question and again that may not be
the case at all um what i'm asking is
have you created a relational context
a relational environment where she feels
safe saying i don't like this
and you're not gonna fly off the handle
roll your eyes get mad be a jerk you'll
be like oh great awesome
yeah i mean i feel like i have him we
don't
you know we don't really fight we're uh
you know we always have fun and happy
and i've told her you know it's like i'm
completely supportive of whatever you
want to do she's she's had like a couple
ideas but
you know where it was like a school
after her four-year degree and you know
completely different area of the country
than i would want to live and i told her
you know
i'm cool with that like we can do it
i'm excited if it's you know if it's
what you want to do if it's what you're
really passionate about but then none of
it you know she kind of gets into a
little bit and it doesn't it's not
really something that she really feels
super passionate about so then she kind
of doesn't want to do that and then so
she doesn't
you know i've tried to you know
like i said i've tried to be as
supportive as i can because i totally am
cool with doing
you know kind of whatever it is because
with my kind of career path i can kind
of go anywhere okay cool
all right so so that so you're not a
jerk that's what i was i was circling up
so that's not you okay you're an open
guy you're super cool to talk to
um so here's the second piece
if in the next six months
she doesn't open up to you
she continues to just be quiet and just
kind of do life the way she wants to do
life and let you lead the way
um
are you thinking about breaking up with
her
no
so you're into this thing
yeah okay
here's where that's important um
i always want to find out where
somebody's values are
okay versus this would be cool if i
would really like it if
the value is i have to
like i need a partner who will
um spar with me intellectually who will
fight for what they want and i'll fight
for what i want and together we'll build
something magical right
if that's something you have to have and
if you're not gonna have it you're gonna
end up getting bored in your marriage
and you're gonna end up seeking that
that connection somewhere else
then go ahead and break up
okay
the other side of it is if you say no
that's just who she is i just wish she
would be more open
then i think you approach that
conversation with
i'm really interested in
you and i building something together
and right now i'm the only person
putting blueprints down on the table
and i feel like you're 50 of this and
i'm i'm missing your half of my heart
and over the next x number
for whatever reason i feel comfortable
talking about that's cool
um she may have been rejected a lot as a
kid she may have been told that her
ideas and opinions don't matter and
she's stupid who knows what her
childhood looks like you would know that
way more than i would
all that to say is what you're gonna
have to do over time is teach her
that her voice matters
okay teach her that her opinion has
weight
and that you
not only you'll just do it but that you
value it
and that she's got wisdom to share in
the hou in your house right and the
whole idea is we're creating something
together it's less what do you want to
do
and who do we want to become together
okay see what i'm saying
yeah that sounds super cheesy
like oh okay
really it's
as simple as
hey i went through instagram or
pinterest and i have five houses that i
think are awesome
this week on our date i want you before
our date i want you to pick five of your
favorite houses
imaginary houses that if we had 10
million dollars we could live in and i
wanted to learn more about why you think
these are beautiful houses
okay there's no pressure there
right or
what's celebrity is the most like man
and woman what's the most attractive
celebrity and why
like
you're taking it off like how would you
like me to do my hair well suddenly
there's a ton of pressure around that if
i say the wrong thing i want to hurt his
feelings one time i said the wrong thing
to my dad and he got mad and hit me who
knows but when it's like oh i like the
way brad pitt does his hair
or he clearly is better than the gym
than you are john right whatever that
whatever that thing is
it takes the pressure off and you're
able to learn about somebody okay
okay so i'm gonna send you
all of them i don't know why not i'm
gonna send you all of them
uh
oh we'll go through i don't know even
which ones we got in house but i'm gonna
send you the questions for humans cards
for dating and the questions for humans
cards for couples the ones for friends
and here's what i want you to do you can
take those cards and all those cards
help you do is practice
safe conversations like healthy
interactions with other people
okay what i'm saying and so y'all can go
to dinner and then the card asks you
what's the best date you've ever been on
that's not me
and suddenly it's like i don't want to
talk about that it's like no i want to
hear what was it it was with tom i hate
tom and now you're in a conversation
right or would you rather burp
or fart or vomit on a first date right
which one
why right now you're having
conversations about why you think this
versus that and i don't want to be
judged i'm going to be shamed and this
would be really embarrassing and i
couldn't come back from this one so now
we're having deeper conversations what
we're doing is we're creating a safe
context so that when
she says i really want this color
curtains or you know what i really want
to go to med school
she's got there's relational equity in
the bank
safety that's that sidewalk of your
relationship the foundation of a
relationship is strong and it's it's
concrete and she can stand on it and she
knows it see what i'm saying
yeah
and so i think it's i think it's
practice and if you're not going to
leave her um and there's not this
nagging thing like i got to solve this
or the marriage is off then i think that
takes the pressure off of you and now
it's about creating a safe context for
her
okay
i do think it's fair to say
um to let her know
my goal with you
is to help create a world where you feel
safe enough to trust me with your
thoughts and hopes and dreams
and she will probably respond with it's
not you you do make me feel safe
um
and i think the next step is to say i
hope that over time
you will come to love and trust yourself
the way i love and trust you
and if i can ever support you in that
journey and learning to love yourself
and trust yourself as much as i love you
and trust you
whether that's counseling whether it's
marriage counseling whether that's a
book study together whatever that looks
like i'm all in
okay see what i'm saying it takes all
the pressure off of do we have to do
this or we have to do that or we have to
it takes all that pressure off which i
think is
and it may be she's got a lot of trauma
to unpack it maybe who knows right maybe
who knows what's there
um
but come what may she's gonna know
james is gonna be right there with me
he's gonna be right here
and that my friend is beautiful it's
awesome
she's lucky to have you dude that's cool
and good luck let me send me a wedding
photo send it our way
and uh we'll post it on the internets we
probably won't do that it's cool though
i'll just say it
i don't know we might i'll post
something right send it to me i'll post
it that'd be great
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right so we wrap up
i didn't know that roy orbison had any
other songs other than pretty woman so
look at me learning things today
i'm just kidding i know he's got other
songs i didn't know what they were but
this one
kelly's fifth favorite song she has this
one tattooed on her arm it's kind of
weird
song is called in dreams
and it goes like this
a candy-colored clown they call the
sandman
start off well kelly
tiptoes to my room every night whoa
just to sprinkle stardust into whisper
go to sleep everything is all right
and i close my eyes and i drift away
into a magic night i softly say a silent
prayer like dreamers do then i fall
asleep to dream my dreams of you it
sounds like a commercial for mdma in
dreams i walk with you in dreams i talk
to you and dreams your mind all of the
time we're together in dreams
and dreams
and ladies and gentlemen in dreams
we're together too and we're actually
together in real life i'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode a few
months ago i discovered that he was
liking other girls pictures on social
media that were inappropriate what does
inappropriate mean bikinis and
showing off their goods
showing off the goods
he can do whatever he wants to
he has no right
none zero to stomp on your values
how do i a loving father of five amazing
daughters handle my hatred and rage
towards this evil person i can't imagine
somebody experiencing what you're
experiencing
and have experienced and not feeling the
exact same way when i'm by myself and
just kind of loaned to my thoughts i
just
i fantasize about hurting this person
like i i want to see this person's world
just burn
and i want to see his family watch it
burn in front of him yep
because that's what he did to
you you